welcome back a year ago tomorrow my next
guest was reporting from Kiev in Ukraine
it's meant to be his last ever job on
the front line Fox News correspondent
Benjamin Hall was covering the war in
Ukraine when he and his crew were hit by
a Russian missile strike that left two
of his colleagues and two Ukrainian
soldiers dead and Benjamin with horrific
injuries well there's a new book out
about these experiences called saved a
war reporter's mission to make it home
it's hit number one in the chants in
America ahead of its release here on
Thursday and Benjamin I'm thrilled to
say joins me now Benjamin great to talk
to you
um it really is because when this
happened it was such an appalling attack
and no one was quite sure about the
scale of your engines but we knew that
four other people had been killed and
frankly it's it's a miracle that you're
here at all
it is and uh I think back to that day
you know constantly and I remind myself
that still being here is the luckiest
thing that happened to me uh and as a
result that we've got to be totally
optimistic every day and make the most
out of life I was the only one who
survived very badly injured I lost my
leg I lost my other foot uh eyesight and
when I was shrapnel in the eye and uh
very badly burned but I've had a whole
year to recover a whole year to push on
through
um and I finally made it and I want to
come back and tell the story not only of
how I was injured but how I recovered
and all the incredible people who came
to evacuate me to save me and to bring
me back one year on well it is an
extraordinary story I I know you've
talked about this before but for our
audience you haven't heard this take me
back to that day this was right at the
the start of the war and the Russians
were trying to take Kiev what happened
we were filming that day just outside
Kiev in a village called harenka totally
abandoned had been bombed to the ground
and we were just filming recording
showing what the Russians had done and
as we were making our way back to the
capital city back to Kiev we stopped at
an abandoned checkpoint and out of
nowhere the first bomb came whistling
overhead and landed about 30 feet in
front of the car we tried to get the car
backwards and um the car stalled and so
cameraman my cameraman Pierre shouted
out of the car get out of the car and
the next second the second bomb landed
right next to the car and that's when I
got a lot of the facial injuries and the
shrapnel in my face and I blacked out
and as I was sitting there unconscious
my daughter came to me I saw my
daughters right in front of me and they
said to me they said Daddy you've got to
get out of the car
and I opened my eyes I came to I crawled
I pulled myself out of the car and then
the third bomb hit the car itself that
one threw me away and I woke up a little
bit later and I was on fire badly
injured and um was lying there next to
our cameraman Pierre who at the
beginning was was still alive but there
was no cell phone reception there was no
way of telling anyone what it what had
happened and I was there for about 40
minutes with my injuries um trying to
figure out how to get home how to get
home to my family and I thought to
myself no matter what happens today I'm
going to find a way home I will do it
and then amazingly a Ukrainian Special
Forces uh car drove past it didn't see
us the first time but I crawled my way
up I pulled my way through the dirt up
to towards the road and amazingly it got
lost and the car came back and I was
ready and I had a handful of grit and
dirt and I threw it at the car and they
saw me and that was the moment about 40
minutes later that I was finally saved
and I hadn't felt any pain until that
moment the adrenaline had been kicking
in but the moment that they grabbed me
and pulled me along the floor to throw
me under the the back of that van I felt
it all all in one second it came back
and the skin all well I won't give you
the details but it was that was where
the next step began where I had to learn
how to get through it having covered war
and reported on other people who'd gone
through this kind of terrible experience
what was the reality like for you to
then be actually living it yourself
yeah it's really interesting and for
years I've seen people who have had
horrible events happen to them I've seen
people you know lose their lives and be
badly injured and I always wondered how
would I react how would it be for me
um and uh I suppose I I'm just very
lucky I from the minute this happened I
realized that we had to get through it
that I had to get through it as best I
could and that if one day for example I
could walk two steps with my new
prosthetic legs the day after that I
would walk Three Steps no matter how
much the pain was one day I would always
do more than I did the day before and um
I think you get pushed to the Limit and
you have to learn a new Strength inside
you and there were times on the
evacuation I was evacuated on the Polish
prime minister's train there was this
covert mission to come in and get me
um incredible Story by
um save our allies it's an American
group that helps evacuate people who are
who are in harm and uh but I remember on
that train ride out without any pain
meds having to figure out you have to
get through some of the worst pain today
and you had to figure out how you're
going to do it and I dug deep and I
thought when I thought I couldn't do it
but there has to be another level inside
you another level to grit to hold on to
realize that if you if you stick
together you can survive so having
finally gone through this myself that's
what I learned I realized that inside
all of us and I think it's true all of
us when you have to you've got to do
something no matter how hard it is you
find a way you keep doing it and you
keep being optimistic about it yeah I
mean you've got extraordinary Spirit
about this I have to say
um
what are your feelings about the fact
that four people including two
journalism colleagues died in this
attack I mean do you think about that a
lot and reflect on that and everything
every single day and I think back to
when I was lying there next to Pierre
um uh someone who was like a brother to
me I'd known him for many years and uh
you know the four others didn't die and
I think that first of all that we a have
to continue doing the job we've always
done it is essential to keep telling the
stories from inside War zones so that
people back home are viewers in our
audience they know exactly what's going
on but I also think that Pierre would
have wanted me to pick myself up and to
live just as Pierre would have done and
that is to make the most out of life go
out and help as many people as I can go
and do the best for my job and for my
family and that's what I do so I think
about him dearly I remember him closely
every single day but it gives me
strength and it reminds me never to give
up just to keep on doing it
what are your thoughts now Benjamin
about the war we're a year on now a year
on from your appalling incident but a
year on with the war is still raging uh
as brutally as it ever has done what are
your thoughts about it yeah you know I
mean in one sense like I think that
we're in an incredible position and the
Russia hasn't taken over the country but
in another sense I think we've reached a
stalemate and I just feel that what we
see at the moment is something that
could go on for years
um if Putin's aim was to tear apart the
country he's done that in a sense
um and I just think it's um the
ukrainians are holding on because of the
support that they're given by NATO by
the US the UK and other countries so uh
I think Putin at the moment is waiting
to see if that support dries up if the
the West stops giving money over the
over the coming years then he might have
another shot at it but I think we've
entered a stalemate at the moment and
the idea that there may be some peace
Accord and that this war ends anytime in
the near future that's not happening in
my opinion and what about for you
because this was going to be one of the
last times you were going to go on a a a
job like this
has it made you rethink that has it
cemented your view do you have other
plans now
well you know I mean one of the reasons
I had decided to pull back was because I
have a family I have three young
daughters my wife Alicia
um they gave me the strength to get
through this but it was one of the
reasons I decided to pull back from
covering so many wars but
um I won't be heading back into war
zones myself or to the front lines but
there is an ongoing discussion at the
moment about interviewing zelenski so
whether or not a trip to Ukraine is in
the cards I'm not sure but I feel
strongly about the job itself and about
people continuing to do this be planned
be prepared know where you're going but
it's essential we keep doing it I've
covered Wars for 15 years and for the
first time ever I think in the near
future I'd rather not tell stories about
the horrors around the world like I've
done I'd like to tell stories about Hope
and optimism and the incredible people
who could pull you through because
that's what I've learned I've learned
how all that help really pulled me
through
um and I would just say to everyone you
know if you know someone who's having a
difficult time reach out those little
words they mean so much and so for my
own career I think maybe initially a
segue into some really uplifting
optimistic stories first deal do your
daughters know about the involvement
they had in you getting out of that car
and surviving
well I mean I've told them that they
saved my life they're still very young
but
they know that I came back to them they
know that we had to we were always to be
together and um I think it's a story
that we'll continue to tell them you
know obviously will talk about it
forever they obviously know and they see
the injuries every day but um
I mean they're my family they're so
special you know when nothing else
counts they count families always there
for you and that's why they're so
important
Benjamin it's great to talk to you it's
great to see you uh everyone obviously
in the whole Fox family was incredibly
worried about you it's a remarkable book
saved a war reporter's mission to make
it home is that on Thursday uh in the UK
this Thursday 16th of March I really
commend people to buy it it's a story of
Hope of inspiration of survival and of
the power of positive thought and I
think that that's been palpable in this
interview so Ben great to see
congratulations on the book Thank you
and the success it's having but also the
message that you're spreading which I
think is so important and I really
appreciate you coming on the show
thank you Pez I appreciate it thank you
all the best
remarkable story a remarkable man